At TED, we're passionate
about public speaking.
Whether sharing from a stage, a podcast,
in a classroom or at work,
being able to effectively
share your ideas
can have a huge impact on your life
and the world.
That's why we've spent the last two years
developing this:
a new mobile app that's fully dedicated
to helping you learn the arts
of identifying, developing,
and sharing your best ideas.
TED Masterclass features
a beautifully animated 11-lesson course,
choice TED Talks that model the concepts
covered in each lesson,
and a continuous flow of exclusive
insights from TED's speaker coaching team.
You can move through the course
at your own pace,
and each lesson will help you master
a discreet presentation skill.
First, you'll learn how to identify,
develop and distill your best ideas.
Next, you'll learn how to prepare yourself
for presenting those ideas.
And finally, you'll learn
a variety of techniques
that'll help you deliver your talk
in ways that will resonate in the minds
of your listeners.
You can download the mobile app
and preview every lesson
in the course for free.
And if you decide to purchase
the full course,
all proceeds will support
the non-profit work
of TED's global education initiative:
TED-Ed.
Learning how to effectively share
your best ideas
creates opportunities for both
you and your audience.
Take the first step towards mastering
the art of public speaking
by checking out TED Masterclass today.